wouldn't monopoly yeah I mean give him
waterworks
[Music]
well scroll cash rate for a Ouija board
what's the reference my name is Kieran I
am a senior banker the reason why I do
what I do is to help individuals with
financial literacy
my name is Amos and I'm a student a
social-media influencer and a Christian
apologist wow that's amazing
my name is Michael Chang I am a founder
CEO of 11 recruiting they love finding
people jobs and creating dreams my name
is Josh Jackson I'm a video editor
that's cuz I love editing videos been
doing it since I was 14 years old
viral you're just leaving alright it's
40 bucks it's 40 but wait you you don't
have a house yet so I don't have a house
it's gonna be a bug swindle me I'm just
trying to struggle in the same struggle
so how much would you chop off a limb
for like how much of a limb how about a
foot no and it would be like a whole arm
or left nipple your non-dominant arm may
be a billion dollars
I'd probably win you in or any price
yeah if you think about a body part and
how priceless it is think about how much
more precious your life is like your
soul anyways five six seven eight if I
have to go to jail oh dude dude you're
incarcerated
[Music]
answer this question or pay a hundred to
the bank how much do you make
I make fifty five a year I think I made
24k this past year me I'm student right
now so I'm technically nothing yeah bye
I'm business owner so technically
nothing but last year my w-2 was
$350,000 can you dump me is it too old
to be a doctor let me get your ball to
Gavin and then you can have this yeah
this is a loss for me but I'll hook it
up now you got a double hey don't gotta
criticized for his decision I am buying
six houses oh don't worry you pass go
you just give me your money
I'll help you out once you get lower I
told Mike the same thing are you play to
win
now just plan to be here the $250 I
would pay my rent I actually have my
niece coming to visit me I actually
thought about this I was looking to
donate it it'll be a great time to take
her around let her do things that she
would like to do I probably would get
some groceries yeah seriously
[Music]
are you satisfied with the amount of
money you have right now at this point
right now I'm pretty satisfied because
I'm pretty big on the whole like
minimalist movement like I don't even
have a couch or nothing you want all
this stuff order you can just like I'm
cool with sit down on the floor my cool
with giving away Baltic Avenue you go
let them live that Bell are you know
that's like I think that's gonna cost
the game yes seriously
no no we'll be okay he's the only person
with a monopoly right now
I felt bad cuz he was in jail but we'll
be okay I'll go to jail do you want to
trade what was the most financially
desperate time of your life how did you
deal with it I all go first
2004 parents moved out so I basically
got rid of the place I was living at I
literally ate TV dinners and microwave
food for like a whole year and a half I
was actually 27 at that time did you
feel because you were such a low
financial like area did that gave you
like a dry oh yeah to like make a
lot of money
it's because I had to go through that
struggle my emotional support was was
limited I saw was on the other side it
was the really good I knew I didn't be
success I knew I was gonna be great at
what I'm doing I just had to get through
this gets the most financially difficult
time of my life was pretty recently
actually I was at a pretty constant
freelance gig I could think where they
would just call me every week and be
like hey King come in these days one day
they just stopped calling do not have to
find something that's more like
consistent Myles was similar to Mike I
was 22 I just was trying to be a
full-time student full-time work and
then my grandmother told me that my
little brothers had to come live with me
and I was already making it on a hundred
dollars a month with groceries and I had
to come to the conclusion that I
couldn't play hero that I had to let my
grandmother know that Wow
I thank you for raising them and
continue that I need you to finish it
for me it's better financially for me to
take care of myself to the bring anybody
else with my struggle it's awesome now
is you for standing for yourself yeah
the imagery that I always say with that
you know on the airplanes when they tell
you always put on your gas mask before
you help others oxygen mask
yeah oxygen mask - yes I wouldn't be
good I guess for me it would be my
childhood as I grew up super poor and
like a lot of nights with no food and
you know gonna sleep hungry
and that's why I don't really idolized
money or possessions but rather I try to
make friends and try to hang out more
gods get I'm here today so alright look
the three of us we need monopolies he
has us he has the ones mean yes so we
got a day a triplet ray so the spokes
give him a green and he gives us yeah
before you give you both the green so
then you have a monopoly give a yellow
listen the game of Monopoly is to wait
it's literally I got a big heart okay
love that yes now we're all in the game
okay all right no I just mean I love you
for that we need more people in life are
you
[Music]
what is a secret to money or success
that everybody should know to make money
yeah they would look to be risk money as
well I'm gonna add to that and in terms
of not being attached to what money
means to you if you disconnect that
attachment to it what dreams it could
create then it opens up a lot of
possibilities I feel like a secret to
success is finding happiness with what
you got right now so if you're happy now
and you get that thing and that's like a
desert baby you know it's like oh
because you're happy already
Amen yeah yeah yeah okay roll the dice
dice roller made dare the others to do
anything to get out of a dare pay $125
to the bank oh that's good dude you're
going to bathroom it's about we roll the
dice and whoever rose highest gets to
created there for him since he's not
here good we made an agreement the
highest roll gets to create a dare for
you what is it do there any man for 15
seconds it's the Running Man thing where
you go just running no running man looks
like you're coming last place in a
marathon what does it mean to be
successful success for me is having a
roof over your head having food on the
table and most importantly having a
family and people that love you and you
love them to me being successful is a
line mate what's your vision it doesn't
have to be monetary or business-wise on
your deathbed I don't think any one of
us in this table is gonna be really like
cherishing the car keys to our Benz
we're like the keys to our mansion yeah
we agree with that your success is
defined by the people who love you
[Music]
Wow I didn't think you would roll out -
okay so I totally lost everything
yeah I'm everything that you got so give
them everything you own if this is a
reflection of how we run my business and
I'm not going look who came up maybe
being generous is our let's cash out
then it's probably you Cowell you catch
up this copycat I'm not gonna count
I'm not part of it
yeah I'm in announced I meant wait what
like 61 she's over 2,000 barrels yeah I
guess being nice good yeah Wow I help
out the people who need another bag this
is the prize yeah
dang dude that's insane
guys conversation I think you won
because you had to go pee I actually
really needed some money
wife and I are really in financial
trouble right now so I'm good
[Music]